underrated by women what is very
important protection
because at the end of the day yeah let's
say me and you we was in the house we
got kids who's a protector of me or you
me that's a dangerous job that's a
that's a constant job that's a forever
job if me and you are outside and
somebody tries to violate who's got to
be the hero me or you me who's going to
risk their life in a dangerous situation
me so at the end of the day I listen I
agree with you if the if if the bills
are being like 50 50 then yeah you're
gonna share some responsibilities but at
the end of the day
the life or death situations always
gonna boil down to the man even if the
man is five foot two he's still gonna
boil down to the man breath do you keep
saying and I think that's very
undervalued by women that's a very bro
like being a man is a dangerous role in
life this is life for instance yeah
you can be outside with a girl who's
good-looking right you go to certain
venues and everybody knows London is
quite dangerous these days yeah bro like
you could go to certain venues and guys
could be angry at you because you got a
good looking girl I want to try you
and potentially want to delete you buff
so I think that girls don't really women
just don't really think about that but
you you know a cognitive of the fact
that when you're on your own and when
you're out there in the world is
dangerous and stuff like that but when
you've actually got a man there that you
can rely on that is there for you that
you can you know he's gonna be your 999
bro like I think women need to
understand that and respect that and
show more respect to their men for the
fact that usually a man will be more
willing to risk his life for his woman
so you're not saying women don't women
how many women have laid down their
lives for their man it don't exist
you're saying that women can't really
equate to that commitment women don't do
it that's what I'm saying women don't do
it
Jose and I think that's very undervalued
and not even represented all women
really talk about these days
is that is that what it it really boils
down to you bro do you get what I'm
saying like bro when you're walking down
the road with your man you're clutching
his armor bro like who's he who's
if you're in the house with your man
there's a bump downstairs who's going
downstairs man
that's it bro who usually dies in horror
films first it's the man breath
everybody's trying their best to save
the woman brav es so what are we
second-class citizens like we're
second-class humans this is what I'm
saying so a lot of women just don't
really rape men like that they don't
really care social protection be number
one be like oh you're a bum but you can
protect me so I'll take you in yeah
I've never ever talked about it's never
taught and I think what like I've had to
I've had there was one situation I
remember yeah I was with this girl and
we went to the club it was like I think
it was my birthday and a couple of my
friends went out and I remember some
guys just like started they was just
chatting rubbish like saying oh what's
that what's that girl doing with that
waste man I was just like bro like I had
to rise up like there was nothing else I
could do because she can't do nothing
and she's looking at me like yeah you're
Batman do you get what I'm saying like
you're Batman you're Superman you're
Spider-Man you gotta do the business
like do you know what I'm saying so I
had to rise up even though like at that
point I was on my own my friends had
gone I was on my own but I had to defend
the situation because if I didn't that
would make us both victims do you keep
saying and at the end of the day with me
rising to the occasion bro I was putting
myself in a dangerous situation because
there wasn't just one guy and I don't
think women really aren't don't because
you don't live that life you don't think
about it bro you just don't do you do
you think that they're that there's
always a situation that a man has to
protect a woman or there's some
situation to where like it can just be
not pushed aside but just gonna walk
away from the situation yeah there's
situations that you can walk away but
really and truly like this world is
dangerous in it so you have to be aware
that that element that that risk is
always there always
you know what I'm saying and again what
I'm saying is I think that a lot of
women just do not think about it because
it's just not in your bubble you know
what I'm saying about men we are aware
of it when we're walking down the street
at 3am we are aware that like bro
something could happen like because if
you guys get attacked like it's you're
cooked but if we get attacked like at
least another man would probably protect
us yeah if I was getting beaten up a guy
people will watch if I was getting
beaten up yeah but like if I got beat up
like even when I was um when I had that
girl like try to attack me in shortage
like guys were kind of like if if she
did anything like guys were the first
ones to come none of them really knew me
and that was a girl yeah and that was a
girl not to talk about if it was a guy
he would get weighed in yeah and be
finished yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah no one's no one's no one's coming
to the the no no one's really coming to
the aid of guys like and I'm not saying
it like oh women need to look after I'm
not saying that but I'm just trying to
make you not understand what you're
saying you'd be like the men need to be
protected at all costs isn't it so yours
to provide yeah but they do because if
you're the protector and you need to be
that you need to be protected is that's
what you're basically saying no I'm just
saying that we may be saying I'm saying
that women need to understand the role
that men play and how important that is
it's not just recognize and appreciate
yeah you're saying that women don't seem
to want to submit to a man unless he
makes a certain amount of money but we
don't appreciate the protection that he
provides because if there was if there
was a blackout tomorrow I think every
girl would be running to their friend
zone and saying please I agree yeah but
I'm not one of those women I'm not one
of those women that think that women
don't need a man
do you know what I mean I'm old school
and I just feel like two they there's
parts that we we provide to them and
they provide for us I agree do you know
what I mean yeah I feel like women are
just more delicate there's things that
we need to be protected more it's even
in Wildlife do you understand you
protect the women and the kids do you
get me I'm I'm more I'm more delicate
I'm more softer than you I'm not as
strong as you so if it comes down to the
Warren who's gonna have to fight if we
have to pick out a me and you you're
gonna have to be the one that's gonna
have to fight for us isn't it
you understand and then I protect the
kids the children after you then it
comes to me but all I'm saying is that
because the initial um point we was
talking about is that oh if you're going
50 50 monetary wise
um does does it make you like basically
50 50 the whole way through it's not 50
50 the whole way through it's not it's
not because just as you said if you go
to war who's going me or you me that's
that's leaving do you think modern women
are lazy
lazy in terms of what to do housework
and stuff
they don't want to do it yeah because
that's the thing like we have more
automation than we've ever had
absolutely but I hear more complaints
about doing it than we ever have when
they used to have to hand wash clothes
yep
they go off or what um
ice cream right what you said about how
your old school and you um just I can't
remember a thing you said but what you
just said about being old school a lot
of
women have taken that mindset in the
role like I need to do this for myself I
need to provide I need to be the
masculine so that that essence of being
old school wanting to be feminine
wanting to just be a woman in a sense is
very slim to none and a lot a woman and
it's not until late that they realize
hmm maybe I should retract how I've been
acting in the masculine way too as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible